i want to pull the story from the post
millennial libby do you want to read
this one sure wait let me get my glasses
i can't see the long way over there
no can you read it yes fox news airs
segment celebrating transgender teen
hannah nightingale wrote this up today i
was shocked when she brought me the
story um
and
said that she was going to write it up
fox news it turns out is as woke as post
mates perhaps they ran a puff piece on a
trans teen out of southern california
and they made claims and the mother
makes claims that it was painful for her
daughter to have to wear feminine
clothing
so that must mean that her daughter is a
boy as though wearing boys clothes makes
you a boy somehow it's like it's a
magical when i put on jeans and t-shirts
oh boy i'm a boy
america look at this look at this fox
news ran yes look at america
together celebrating diversity
lgbtq plus pride month please i have
really strong words that i would like to
say to fox news but this is my 7 million
family youtube video brian yenis has the
story about that family that hopes their
experience can help others watch here
if you saw me walking down the street
you wouldn't
think anything different
fourteen-year-old ryland whittington is
a typical southern california teenager
and the whittingtons along with mom
hillary dad jeff and sister all right
whatever look yeah
my my it is uh whatever i think well
where's the news where's the right i
know like i have two questions like i
don't understand why fox news is airing
this story i don't either i look because
they're owned by black rock the ques the
issues i have are around
lack of parental rights so in the
schools if the if the children are being
exposed and keeping a seat from their
parents if the parents are making
decisions for their their kids well
there's questions about you know where
the parents rights are
and the the issue of
surgery
on children i don't know the full depth
of the story i think for me what i can
comment on is
why is fox news airing this
it's a really good question as to why
fox news is airing this and i think
somebody should ask fox news why the
why they are airing this
why they would be conceivably airing a
puff piece on a trans teen
um who if this teen goes through with
all of the the transness will end up
leading a life where they can never have
an orgasm i mean they're saying it's uh
quote for me it's a deep spiritual
belief that if you believe in god and he
you know created us the way he wanted us
well then yes he created ryland just the
way he is said the mother right which
which means that he that that rylan
needs nothing to be who rylan truly is
doesn't need any drugs doesn't need any
surgery doesn't need any changes cut
your hair wear whatever clothes you want
in fact without anything that's when you
are who
this is a news corp which owns fox and
they have about seven percent of the
company is owned by the the triad block
rack block rap block black lock rack
vanguard states there's other one called
independent franchise partners i think
what they're doing is this is a mutton
bailey they give you the the um
the uh staged opposition you know the
the controlled opposition for a while
they did that for last couple years now
you're starting to see the real
propaganda controlled opposition is the
word here that i think is key to to
really understand a lot of the motives
of some of the republicans and some of
the republican news networks i mean
again what's the purpose here what's the
relevance how is this impacting my life
what does this have to do with me living
my life every single day it has nothing
to do with it and why am i being told
about this like it's crazy what news has
turned out to be well and it's not just
why are you being told about this it's
why is fox encouraging parents to gender
transition their children yeah because
that is what's going on here this is no
different than when president biden got
there got up there on trans visibility
day or whatever that whatever it was
called um sorry i'm having trouble
yeah me too yeah
i'm trying why would why would anyone oh
i'll say this i mean yeah you know but
instead of that spider told parents to
gender transition their children right
outside of this story which um
you know i'm just going to say you know
as an aside man i think it's a good
opportunity for people who are members
of fox nation to sign up for timcast.com
that is such a great idea
i totally stand private corporations
these public corps are dangerous these
people whoever ran this has absolutely
no ethics hey you know they're no
different than cnn you know who's not
owned by blackrock vanguard all these
people that's tim castos
well i will say that the post-millennial
and our sister publication human events
we are also not owned there's also
another group called we are change out
there
are you also independent
that was a big part of what elon was
doing well you know it's he wants to
make it make it private and i think that
he's right we went to you know vanguard
straight state street in blackrock and
they didn't they rejected us and then i
was just like well we don't want your
money anyway we're independent and you
suck
they they do suck no i'm good
i was outside waving my fist at them i
know what you're up to how many people
do you think are involved with owning
those corporations
well they they have commercials
and they tell people to put their
investment their their retirements yeah
we saw them last night yeah yeah they're
like invest with us i should start using
a different word than a corp megacorps
megacorps but even that is a word
corporation you know what about like
uh aberration eldritch horror yeah yeah
these horrors
what do you think about 20 guys am i
this is conspiracy theory time luke what
do you think
20 people own these companies do you
think it's more than like way more than
that some people say 13 but uh
who really knows yeah that's a that's a
hand like the heads of families yeah
well the num i mean maybe if we got that
client list we might know you know what
i'm saying
yeah and the thread pulls deep on this
one remember the panama papers boy did
that get swept
so quickly it was like a woman and she
got murdered right yep
wait she got murdered how did i miss
that part i guess because it got covered
up by fox news and cnn which may as well
be the same company when i go to sleep
at night my my nightmares are that it's
already on lockdown the whole world is
already on corporate lockdown by these
companies and that we are just along for
the ride you just were two years ago
yeah two years ago we were on corporate
lockdown but lockdown like spy network
satellites watching they're ready to
kill anyone at any time lockdown like
just fall in line or die kind of thing
it's terri
i hope it's not like that but man i i
know that they have satellites i don't
know
yeah elon musk satellites that he's
using right now in uh ukraine so what
you got a trick you gotta trick the
world into changing
yeah i make them laugh their way to the
bank you have to you have to give people
and you have to like
tell people
how to find meaning and fulfillment in
their lives and not even how to but to
go search for that to go search for you
know don't tell people what to believe
or how to believe it but tell them with
an expression of faith
to go find these things for themselves
to figure it out to ask you know i think
i think one of the ways the right wing
has really really failed has not been
giving a positive goal for people
because as we were saying before it's
constant reaction it is yeah and the
constant reaction is no way to move
forward you're not moving forward right
you're just saying this is bad this is
bad when you're standing with what
history yelling stop and it does need to
be it does need to be positivity you
need to you need to like
give some way to find a path i i think
of this woman that i talked to at tpusa
or who asked this question constantly
because i'm thinking like uh because one
of her questions was if you
um if you have no framework for meaning
or for a soul or for faith
how do you find it where do you begin if
you have absolutely don't have the
language we've taken the language away
from kids about meaning about faith
about a soul about you know any of this
stuff and we've replaced it with gender
garbage
you know so fully
where do you begin
if you are devoid of all meaning if you
are you know miserable and you think
that it's all in your brain you don't
even have the words to go find
what it is that will that will help you
yeah it's the scientific method has been
there's too much weight and importance
put on that i think in our society
because it only can indicate what's it
just looks for patterns and if it can't
find a pattern it tells you it's not
real but the thing about god if there is
such a thing is it's not the same if
it's a pattern it's happening from
really far away and it looks like chaos
to us but there's still
something to it
i suspect that the right will win in the
end because they are actually asking
these questions and the left never will
we are at least attempting to be
somewhat self-aware the right's going to
win because they have kids yeah that's
true too that's it that's true too but
when you teach your kids that you want
to search for a purpose and meaning and
that that purpose and meaning is not
found within yourself and that's
incredibly solipsistic to think that it
is
then you're gonna have more success in
life overall and you're gonna be happier
like having kids is great but if they're
miserable and they're ready to be trans
what's the point it's like not having
kids at all you have to you have to
share
faith and love of life with them right
and you have to be in that position and
you know word too yeah and what's
interesting too is the way that we treat
children now is we treat them like
you know just another pleasure object
right if you look at this whole thing um
there's a doctor in india who is
certified by some board in the u.s
who is
planning to transplant a uterus into a
man good luck so that that man can feel
further feminine and this is after like
drastic reconstruction and like all of
the rest of it um
there is absolutely no thought given to
now first of all it's going to fail but
there's secondarily there's no thought
given to
what will happen to this child this
child will be the product of an egg from
one person
the uterus for you know an egg from one
woman a uterus from another woman be
gestated in the body of a male who is
actually only doing this for their own
personal fulfillment to feel more female
uh
who who is this child who's this child's
mother who's the father my question is
like how do they attach the uterus well
it's gonna not work yeah it already um
it already didn't work in mice like it
actually
is is it is as stupid as it sounds
but even when you think about like
surrogacy or other things where you have
a child that is conceived and gestated
from like you know half a dozen people
or whatever
where are you from
what's your background what's your
culture
what's you know who's your mother
who's your daddy yeah
who's your daddy yeah that's the big
question these days right it is yeah uh
your environment i suppose genetics you
know obviously you're past the show the
tree comes into it but who's raising you
who's who's raising you and where are
you from i mean at a certain point you
know like when you talk to people who
have been adopted and they everyone
wants to know who their original parents
were at some point and when i feel like
maybe we're probably the issue here is
that we're placing far too much emphasis
on the physical body this is why we're
doing insane things like transplanting a
female uterus into the pelvis of a male
never going to work you should maybe
talk about your soul instead i want to
make sure we get to this think about
your soul thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you